[Music]
Congrats on being here again with this
incredible show I'm so excited you'll
never get all in such a fun award show
the Zags never go none of them ever get
old and this is such a so far removed
from where I come from this is always
good fun it's so nice to like see the
other cast members and all the bus hang
out we don't get a chance to hang out
much all together as a group on set
because we're all in such different
storylines but it's so nice to come
through Awards like the boy shows like
this because we all get to just have fun
we know Stevens season 7 coming up
season 8 has been said to be the last
one and you've said that you're a little
scared about that at all wrap it on it's
been your security boy yeah definitely
it has been my security blanket it's
been a bit of a safety net if I haven't
if I haven't worked and I haven't landed
a role like I never beat myself up too
much because I've always got Game of
Thrones and to not have that around it's
going to be really strange but it's also
exciting it means I can now shape my
career and and I'm not tied into
anything and I can really make bold
decisions I hope and how are you you
know in a sense preparing to say goodbye
to this role because that's a big deal
um I'm just trying to do the last the
last few scenes that I have justice I'm
just trying to shape Aria the way that I
have been so far and give her a nice arc
to end with and hope the people are
happy with it
[Music]
you